hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
strategies to optimize drug testing
what's in your panel and what are you
missing
i am michelle ashton of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as we
want and any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr jamie
noga the medical director of chemistry
and toxicology at university hospital
cleveland medical center
assistant professor of pathology at case
western reserve
university for a complete biography on
our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
jamie you may now begin your
presentation
thank you michelle for the introduction
and i'd like to thank all of you for
attending this webinar
some quick housekeeping um the thoughts
and views in this presentation are
my own and do not reflect those of
thermo fisher scientific
but i would like to thank them for
sponsoring this webinar
all right so the objectives of my talk
today are several fold i'll start by
introducing the concept of toxicology
testing
and then describes some of the various
technologies that are available and
commonly used
in drug testing i'll provide some
examples of several clinical scenarios
where drug testing is commonly requested
and then describe some approaches that
you can use to design your drug test
panels to ensure that they meet the
various clinical needs
let's get started so there are many
important decisions that need to be made
to ensure that your drug
testing program meets your stated goals
and is successful
and so an important first step then is
to understand how the urine testing
process works
what the testing cannon cannot tell you
so we'll get started by reviewing some
basic context
or concepts in drug testing
so a toxicology screen is a test that
checks for drugs or other chemicals in
your blood
urine or saliva um when i say blood i'm
referring to serum or plasma which is
what's most commonly tested
a top screen can check for one
particular drug or for many different
drugs all at once and so this can
include prescription medications
over-the-counter drugs like aspirin or
things like vitamins
supplement alcohol and even illicit
drugs like cocaine
there are four general categories of
toxicology testing
there is forensic toxicology testing
which is conducted by a laboratory for
medical legal purposes
there's workplace drug testing which is
often done pre-employment as part of the
interview process
or after someone's already been hired on
as random drug testing to
enforce a drug-free workplace there's
athletic drug testing
which typically looks for banned
substances or performance enhancing
agents and this is
typically done in competitive level
athletes and then there's clinical drug
testing
which is conducted to assist in patient
diagnosis and treatment
so my talk today is going to focus on
this last category clinical drug testing
so i'd like to give you some examples of
common scenarios
clinical scenarios where drug testing is
ordered
it's often ordered in the emergency
department when a patient presents
the ed with a suspected overdose or
poisoning
if they've been involved in an accident
where there's injuries and there's any
suspicion of substance abuse
if they present with life-threatening
symptoms they're unconscious or if
they're exhibiting strange behavior
a physician might think that they should
order a drug test
another scenario is controlled substance
monitoring so in these situations the
physician is looking for the presence of
the medication that they prescribed in
order to gauge compliance
they're also looking to ensure the
absence of non-prescribed medications or
any illicit substances that the patient
may be taking
another example is therapeutic drug
monitoring so in these scenarios the
physician is checking drug
concentrations to ensure that they are
at the appropriate levels
in order to provide optimal therapeutic
effect for their patients
they're often ordered for evaluating
perinatal maternal substance abuse right
so this allows us to facilitate
placement of these expectant mothers
into treatment
programs
yet another example is an addiction
recovery program
to monitor treatment plans and to
identify relapse
and so these are just a few examples of
how drug testing
is ordered in the clinical setting but
in general it can be ordered in any
situation where you want to detect drug
use or abuse where you think it can have
a negative impact on patient care
so we can do these testings in a number
of different matrices
so serum and plasma hair urine
saliva sweat and breath
but the most commonly used matrix in
clinical testing is urine
and that's there's several reasons for
that so urine collection is non-invasive
meaning that you don't require
phlebotomist to do it the patient can
collect it themselves
typically there's more than enough
volume to do the testing that you need
to
there are long detection windows
relative some of the other matrices
so if you look at the table to the far
right you'll see that
there's a chart with the relative window
of drug detection for various matrices
with urine being
right in the middle of that table and so
we have a range of minutes to sometimes
even weeks
for detecting some of these drugs most
drugs and their metabolites tend to be
excreted in urine in higher
concentrations than what they're found
in blood which makes them easier to
measure
and the analysis is relatively simple
compared to some of the other matrices
because
it's pretty clean so there's not a lot
of proteins or things in it that would
make it technically challenging to
measure
that being said there are still some
challenges with
measuring drugs and urine so urine can
be easily substituted
diluted or adulterated unless you're
performing an observed collection which
often is not done in the clinical
setting
the donor may be unable to provide a
specimen at the time that you need them
to so they could have a shy bladder
there's a lack of correlation between
the drug level with intoxication
and drug levels can vary widely so you
can give two different patients the same
drug the same dose and they can have
different levels of
the drug in the metabolite in their
urine
so drugs vary considerably and how
quickly they pass through our body
and that they can be detected in our
urine and so this variation depends on a
number of things
including the nature of the drug itself
so it's kinetics of distribution
so what's its half-life um what's its
solubility does it prefer to stay in our
bloodstream or does it accumulate in our
fatty tissues
it depends on an individual's metabolism
which is a
dependent on their liver function or
their kidney function so how quickly
they can metabolize and excrete it from
their body
it depends on the hydration status of
the patient prior to sample collection
the frequency of drug use so whether
they are
using it just one time versus chronic
use
in the time and size of last dose i'd
like to direct your attention to the
table on the right so this
shows the approximate drug detection
times and urine of several drugs and
drug classes
and so i'm not intending to go through
each line but i just want to highlight
that there are some drugs
or some substances that we can detect
for a very short window like alcohol
others that we can detect on the order
of days like oxycodone so roughly two to
four days
but then there are substances like long
axis long-acting benzodiazepines
or chronic marijuana use where we can
detect on the order of weeks
so there's quite a bit of variation
there are two main types of urine drug
tests so there's a drug screen
which is an initial test that we can use
to identify potentially positive and
negative specimens
and these results are typically reported
out as preliminary presumptive or
unconfirmed
positive and negative results then
there's a drug confirmation which is a
more
specific test that provides definitive
identification of the drugs in the
sample
as well as their metabolites and so
these results are often reported out as
definitive or confirmed
positive or negative results
immunoassays are the methodologies that
are typically used for this type of
screening
because they're sensitive quick
inexpensive and they really only require
a small amount of sample
they rely on the interactions between
antigens and antibodies to detect the
presence of
either an entire drug class so opiates
as an example of an entire class
or a particular drug like cocaine
they are usually qualitative and they
can indicate the presence or absence of
a drug or to metabolite at a given cut
off
and so these cutoff varies levels can
vary depending on which drug you're
testing
and they're established by the met the
manufacturer to help minimize the number
of false positives
so if you look at the table on the
bottom right this just shows an example
of a number of different drug tests and
in the parentheses the cut offs that
have been
assigned for them so
for these screens they're fairly
sensitive but they're not specific
so we are sacrificing some of the
specificity in order to achieve broad
reactivity
and detect drugs in an entire class
so these qualitative screens or these
immunoassays their cutoffs
are calibrated or set using a
representative drug
and so this is a compound that's
intended to represent the entirely
structurally similar class
and so the chart here shows just a
representation of some of the
representative
drugs and cutoffs that might be used i'm
using it only
for the sake of making a point and
explaining a concept
so i will use the opiate assay as
the example with morphine as a
representative drug
setting a cutoff at 300 nanograms per
mil
all right so the cutoff is set then by
running a
known concentration of morphine which
would be 300 nanograms per mil here
which will be our standard in our assay
and it will generate a signal
and we see that 300 nanograms per
morphine
generates an absorbance of 0.80
so when we go to run our patient sample
our unknown
any samples that generate a signal of
0.8 or above would be considered
positive
and anything that generates a signal
that's less than that or maybe no signal
at all will be considered
negative that's easy enough pretty
straightforward
but one of the challenges or limitations
of amino acids is that they demonstrate
variable detection of compounds within a
drug class
so what do i mean by that so i'll
further expand on this on the next slide
continuing on with the opiate screen as
an example
so typical opiate immunoassays they're
designed to detect the natural opiates
and their metabolites
so in the table below they're shown in
green here the natural opiates are those
that are derived from the opium plant
directly so these are your morphine
codeine etc and their structures are
shown at the bottom left of the screen
with the names in green then there's the
semi-synthetic opioids
so these are not exactly derived from
the plant
but they have the same chemical backbone
that's been modified to modulate their
biological activity
so these are your hydrocodones oxycodone
hydromorphone etc
listed in gold in this table and their
chemical structures are shown in the
middle
of the slide and so just by looking at
these you can see that their structures
are very very similar to the natural
opiates which we would expect
then there's a totally different class
there's a synthetic opioid so these are
manufactured completely they are fully
fabricated there's nothing natural about
them these are your methadones your
fentanyl and your tramadols
and if you look at their chemical
structures shown on the bottom right of
the
the screen you can see that they are
structurally very different
right than either the natural opiates or
the semisynthetic opioids
so as humans we tend to categorize these
drugs
as opioids opioids right because of the
biological effect they have on our
bodies
but the actual immunoassay or the test
actually categorize them quite
differently right so
the ability for them to detect the drugs
within a class will vary as the chemical
structures change
but to further drive this point home
then in blue
i have the the concentrations that are
needed to produce a positive opiate
screen
using a cutoff of 300 nanograms terminal
as i described
so obviously for this assay we would
only need 300 nanograms per ml of
morphine to trigger a positive result
because that's what we used to calibrate
it
but notice that we need less coding to
trigger the same
uh signal or to generate the same signal
we would need about
five times as much oxycodone to generate
the same
signal amplitude and we would need about
50 times or more
of fentanyl to create the same signal
so the ability to detect drugs within a
class varies as the chemical structures
change
thankfully our assay manufacturers
include this cross-reactivity
information in their package inserts so
they have information about the compound
that they're tested
uh testing and then the concentration
that's required to trigger a positive
reaction in their particular method
this is just an example of one here and
you'll see that
they also include the concentrations
required of many of the metabolites so
morphine metabolizes to hydromorphone
and you can see from this chart that you
need roughly 500 nanograms per ml of
hydromorphone to trigger this result
um as uh this test to be positive so
almost twice as much
of the morphine metabolite as morphine
itself
so this is a very helpful tool for some
food for thought then
a negative urine drug spring does not
always indicate that a substance isn't
present right it can also indicate that
there's just poor cross reactivity of
that particular substance in that screen
that the substance is present it's truly
there but it's just below the
established cutoff concentration
that the specimen was collected at a
less than optimal time relative to drug
administration so you're not able to
detect as much of it
or that the specimen was somehow diluted
or adulterated in a way
that prevents it from being measured
i'd like to continue on with this
concept of cross reactivity so
cross reactivity occurs when a test
cannot distinguish between the substance
that's being tested for
and the substances that are chemically
similar and so this is a good thing in
some ways right because this gives us
uh the broad cross reactivity we need to
detect an entire class of drugs
but there's a flip side to that it's a
double-edged sword and that
sometimes you might also pick up on
things that you're not really looking
for
and so i feel like this is well
illustrated in the cartoon below
well so i'll walk through this so we
have an assay that has anti-a antibody
that's designed to detect antigen a
which is this upside down
looking uh t structure anti-a
in a body is not very specific so it's
also able to detect antigen b which has
a shared epitope with antigen a
so the light blue portion of antigen b
is what's shared with antigen a and then
the yellow portion is what's unique to
antigen b
now because anti antibody a
is not very specific it can also cross
react with antigen c
which doesn't share any epitopes with
antigens a or b
but it just looks structurally similar
it's a similar epi looking epitope so
it kind of looks like an upside down t
so how does this relate to drug testing
then
so you have an assay that's designed to
detect amphetamine
it's also able to detect methamphetamine
because they
share an epitope they're very
structurally similar
but it'll also detect bupropion right
because if you look at this
from a 3d perspective and chemically
they look very very close
so your assay may not be able to tell
the difference between the two of them
so uh practitioners and laboratorians we
should be familiar with this potential
for cross reactivity
um and ensure that our physicians are
asking their patients about what other
prescriptions they're on whatever over
the counter medications they might be
taking
that may potentially cause a false
positive in their test in their drug
screening test
this is also where confirmation testing
comes into play and comes in very handy
so confirmatory drug testing it can be
used to confirm the results of a
screening test
whether it's positive or negative so it
could be used to confirm that the
screening test in fact detected the
target compound and not something that's
just structurally similar
but you could also use it to confirm
that there isn't any drug
present at a concentration that's below
the cutoff threshold
typically this type of testing is done
using a higher level method
using technologies that can separate and
quantitate compounds based on their
chemical properties as well as their
mass and so
most commonly gas chromatography mass
spectrometry
and liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry are used and so in the
upcoming slides i'll touch more and
describe and
describe these technologies
but confirmation testing can also
identify specific drugs within a class
so instead of just being able to say
that someone is positive for opiates you
can specifically say that they are
positive for the drug
oxycodone as well as its metabolites nor
oxycodone and oxymorphone
confirmatory testing also provides
quantitative concentration so you not
only know
exactly which compound is in there but
how much of it is present
the limit of detection for these tests
tend to be lower than screening tests
because of the nature of the method
and they provide higher sensitivity and
specificity than screens
so just a quick review then about these
technologies
chromatography is a collective term that
we use for a variety of lab techniques
that can separate the components of a
mixture into its individual parts
so that we can analyze identify purify
and quantify them
so most biological matrices so that
we're testing in the clinical setting
they're very complex
and that can make complete
characterization quite challenging so
this is where we can use chromatography
to help us
separate the components of a mixture
so the components of the sample are
separated based on the distribution
between two phases there's a stationary
phase which is as it sounds stationary
stays still
and then there's a mobile phase which is
pushed through the stationary phase
now the composition of these two phases
can vary depending on the intended use
and by that i mean it depends on what
compound you're trying to separate so
the user gets to choose the properties
of each of these phases
substances that have the weakest
interaction with the stationary phase
they will pass through faster
than those that have strong interactions
so you end up having several different
fractions with different molecules
eluding at the time that reflects
their level of interaction with the both
phases
mass spectrometry is an analytical
technique that we use for the
quantitative analysis of compounds
within a sample based on their mass
so in general all mass spectrometers
they have these basic components they
have an
ion source a mass analyzer and an ion
detector
now the nature of these components can
vary you can mix and match
there's different types and create
different types of instruments but in
general mass specs have these basic
components
so the samples are loaded into the inlet
they are then vaporized meaning they're
turned into a gas
and then they are ionized at the ion
source
they then move into the mass analyzer
which separates the ions based on this
mass to charge ratio
and then they go into an ion detector
where these charged particles can be
detected
and we can get a chromatogram that tells
us what particles are detected and the
relative abundance of each
and so using that data we can either
identify compounds by correlating the
masses that we're seeing to the known
masses of the compounds that we're
looking for
or through a characteristic
fragmentation pattern that matches a
compound that we know fragments the same
way
so when you pair chromatography with
mass spectrometry you are able to
improve the specificity of your drug
testing
so gc and lcms they separate analytes in
a sample
based on their retention time and their
mass so you can be very confident that
you're detecting the molecule that
you're interested in
if it won it looks at a specific time
from the column
and two if it has a specific mass in
charge
so some of the advantages of using mass
spec in the clinical setting
are that you have high sensitivity and
specificity
the linear range can be quite wide so
you don't have to do as many dilutions
it has high accuracy and precision
you can remove many of the non-specific
antibody interferences that you would
see from immunoassays
depending on how you develop your method
they can have short run times
and require actually quite low sample
volumes
massbat can be a cost effective solution
for drug testing
but i would say that the initial outlay
of capital is quite expensive but the
actual reagent thereafter is quite
inexpensive
and then for the last two points on here
i wanted to specifically highlight
because i think that they're
particularly pertinent for drug testing
so mass spectrometry gives you the
opportunity to multiplex
your testing so that means that you can
test for several different compounds
at the same time in a single injection
so for example
the method one of the methods that we
run at our institution
we can measure 66 different compounds in
just 100 microliters of
urine so instead of doing testing
sequentially we can test for all of
these at once in the same injection
another benefit of mass spec when it
comes to
drug testing is that you can detect and
differentiate the parent compounds from
the metabolites
so for those of you who aren't
particularly familiar with the opiate
and benzodiazepine metabolism so these
are just some of the more commonly
ordered
medications at least in our system i
just wanted to highlight that
you will sometimes see a mixture of
parent compounds and the metabolites
sometimes you'll only see the
metabolites so it's good to build your
method in a way that you have
both the parent compound and the
metabolites and as you can see here
the boxes that are kind of a light pink
color
these are the prescription drugs the
ones that are kind of a grayish color
those represent the metabolites and so
you can see that some of these compounds
they are metabolites of other compounds
but they're also
drugs in their own right
so some of the potential pitfalls of
mass spectrometry
are patient-specific ion suppression so
this is a decrease in sensitivity in an
individual patient sample
so there's something in that specific
patient sample that elutes off the
column at the same time as a compound
that's of interest to you
and it prevents it from being measured
accurately
another type of interference are
isobaric interferences so this
is when two compounds have the same mass
and you can't sell them apart
unless you separate them
chromatographically
for mass spec additional sample prep
might be needed
example is if you're trying to measure
total drug concentrations
so most drugs or many drugs are
metabolized in the liver
when they go through our liver a
glucoronide group is attached to it to
make the drug water soluble so that we
can excrete it in our urine
so if you want to measure total drug
concentration you either have to
look for the mass of the parent drug and
the drug with the glucoronide attached
to it
or you could do something called a
hydrolysis reaction where you take that
glucoronic group
off and you're just looking for the
parent compound or its metabolite
so there could be quite a bit of sample
prep required
and then finally the complexity of this
technology can make it not only
difficult to implement but
quite challenging to maintain if you
don't have the expertise on site
all right so now i'm shifting into the
the next part of this talk where we're
talking about drug testing approaches
so in most clinical labs urine drug
testing is traditionally been a two-step
process where you start with a screen
and then anything that's positive will
reflex to a confirmation
and so this testing scheme it was
designed a long time ago to detect drugs
of abuse and workplace testing
and then it was adopted into the
clinical setting
but as our need to manage uh treatment
of chronic pain has evolved so have our
approaches for testing so now there's
more than one approach
so some of these aim to reduce the
number of false positives
others aim to reduce the number of false
negatives as well
and so it's it's pretty important then
to define early on how you're going to
use the test so that you can pick the
approach
that best meets the clinical need
so the next slide i'm just going to
to share with you some general drug
testing approaches that are used so this
is not meant to be a
prescription for you to do any of these
but i just want to share with you
what's out there and to open your mind
to the possibility of using different
approaches depending on the clinical
scenario so the first
approach that i'll describe is the one
step approach and so this is where
only an immunoassay screen is used and
then
it's used to treat patients so the
results are used to make a clinical
decision right then
and there an example of where this might
be used is the emergency department
so if someone a patient presents with a
suspected overdose perhaps in a sickle
cell
crisis or having seizures a physician
might order a drug screen
just to know what's on board so that
they can make a decision right then and
there to treat the patient
that being said i do have to put out the
disclaimer that these screening assays
only do provide
preliminary results and so the
instructions for use for them
um do say that confirmation is
uh recommended so clinical consideration
and professional judgment should always
be applied to any of these results
particularly when there's a preliminary
result
that's generated
the next approach is a two-step approach
so this is where an amino acid screen is
is what you start out with and then
anything that's positive will
automatically be reflex to a
confirmation if it's positive
so some clinical scenarios where this
might be used would be
pre-admission testing in the inpatient
setting so for example a labor and
delivery award or pre-transplant
evaluation
you might also see this in or this might
be useful in the primary care setting
for general screening
and then we have a third approach this
is described as an orthogonal or a
hybrid approach
so in this approach an immunoassay is
ordered for some drug classes and a
confirmation test is ordered directly
for others
so instead of doing it two-step or
step-wise you're ordering them both at
the same time and running them at the
same time
so some examples where this type of
approach might be helpful would be in
the pain management or controlled
substance monitoring setting
where a clinician will want to order
directly a confirmation testing for
the substances that they know that they
prescribe the patient and then do a
screen for
all the other classes
so this slide shows the several
different flavors
of these orderable drug panels so how
you can operationalize those different
approaches and so
these are panels that we offer at my
institution so we have just our basic
urine drug screen
which is a nine component screen as
shown here
now if a result comes up as presumptive
positive nothing else happens
the result goes out and it's up to the
physician to either call the lab or go
into
our uh electronic physician order entry
and place an order for a confirmation
test to be added on
the next level of test we have is a
urine drug screen with reflex to
confirmation if positive and it's
literally named that
in our emr um this
this test has the same exact nine
component panel
except for if anything comes up as
positive it automatically reflexes to a
confirmation so there's a rule built in
our laboratory information system
that says if any of these screens come
up positive
automatically order a confirmation for
that test so we found this to be
particularly helpful
in settings where there may be medical
legal consequences
or in the outpatient setting when a
physician would order a test but not
have the time to
look at the results and call the lab to
add on the confirmation testing before
we'd already discarded the sample
and so typically given the volume of our
hospital we really can't store samples
for more than
probably about three days and so a lot
of physicians were missing that window
and then upset because we weren't able
to add on the confirmation so this was
definitely helpful there
um the next flavor of assay that we have
is something that's much more specific
to a particular clinical scenario so
this one is just uh it's named
opiate benzodiazepine prescription
compliance panel so it's very
obvious what it's intended to be used
for which is gauging prescription
compliance to
someone who's prescribed an opiate or
benzodiazepine drug
so in this panel we use the orthogonal
approach or the hybrid approach right
where we're ordering
opiate opioid and benzodiazepine
confirmation up front
and then for all the other drug classes
we are doing a screen
and if any of those urine direct screens
are positive that will also
automatically reflex to a confirmation
so these are some examples of how we've
chosen to
operationalize these different
approaches in our lab panels
and we don't have panels for every
single scenario every
single clinical department many
departments can benefit from
just a single panel for example i would
say most people tend to use our urine
drug screen with reflux to confirmation
all right so our pathology department
has worked very closely with a number of
other
specialties to create our institutional
drug testing guidelines
so none of these decisions were made
unilaterally by the laboratory so
we collaborated with the pain management
institute with the primary care
institute
with our legal and risk management
departments when we were defining our
controlled substance monitoring
guidelines
and when we were trying to figure out
what panels and approaches that needed
to be used for inpatient drug testing
we had representation from several
inpatient loads
our emergency department i.t to make
sure things were flagging
a certain way or being pulled from our
emrs
the legal risk management and social
services departments
so i strongly recommend
interdisciplinary
collaboration when defining your drug
testing guidelines for your institution
i will say that we often refer to
clinical practice guidelines when
possible
so if they were out there we brought
them to the table for discussion with
the group
so some examples of helpful guidelines
that i found to be helpful in my career
this one is the monitoring drug therapy
and pain management patients and so this
was
co-sponsored by the american association
of clinical chemistry
and the american academy of pain
medicine so this is particularly helpful
in developing that opiate opioid benzo
panel
we also refer to consensus statements so
one example is the american society of
addiction medicine
um and we also refer to just committee
opinions that are published so
this was a a joint publication by the
american college of obstetricians and
gynecologists
along with the american society of
addiction medicine on
opioid use and abuse disorder in
pregnancy and the testing
recommendations
so i find all of these helpful um
whenever there were guidelines available
we would bring them to the table
if there weren't any it was always a
discussion with a much larger group
outside of the laboratory
all right so the next part of this talk
relates to designing and optimizing drug
test panels
so before you start deciding what
individual components you should have
for your your test panels you really
should take a step back and
start by defining how the test will be
used what's the goal
is the goal to detect drug use to detect
drug
abuse or perhaps both and what patient
population do you intend on using this
on
is it meant for addiction medicine is it
meant for the emergency department what
are the specific needs of that patient
population
and that can help to help you decide
what components you need to have in your
panel and what makes most sense for that
particular population
but i urge you to also consider these
other essential features
like what analytical performance
characteristics are required
is a qualitative result sufficient or
does it need to be quantitative
what threshold should you use do you
need higher or lower cutoffs
what specimen types do you want to
accept serum urine etc
in some patient populations such as
those that have let's say
kidney disorder they may not be able to
produce a urine sample as easily
so you'd also want to have a serum
version of the same panel available
what turnaround time requirements are
acceptable so
um the clinical utility of a test has to
do with
uh well part of it is how quickly you
can get the results back so if someone
in the emergency department
sends out for a drug test and they don't
get the results back for a week that
doesn't really help them in that moment
right because the patient will already
be discharged before them so just
thinking about what turnaround time
requirements make the most sense for how
that test is being used
by considering all of these elements
this will help to ensure that you're
creating drug testing panels and
processes that are best suited for the
clinical need
in question
another place that you can start where i
recommend starting your panels
is by referring to the federal
government guidelines
so the federal government mandates that
these specific classes of drugs are
included in a federal workplace drug
testing program
so these are amphetamines cannabinoids
cocaine
opioids and phencycline which is pcp
so a long time ago the substance abuse
and mental health services
administration
they deemed that these were the five
drug
categories that were most commonly
abused and so that's why they must
be in all federal workplace drug testing
programs so most clinical labs will at a
minimum start with these five drug
classes
but many labs decide to expand their
screening panels
and so some of the additional drugs you
might decide to include maybe
barbiturates
benzodiazepines fentanyl methadone there
are a number
of drug tests that are out there how do
you know which one
to add to your panel and so
it can be challenging so my advice to
you
our three additional tips are to one
test for drugs that are commonly abused
or prescribed so the drug panels that
you have available
they should be a reflection of the
substances that are being used or abused
within your community
would avoid the urge to add trendy
designer drugs so
test for synthetic cannabinoids or bath
salts i'd avoid adding those to your
conventional drug test panels unless you
have the ability to frequently update
them
so the compounds that are in designer
drugs they change and evolve very
quickly in order to
um to prevent being scheduled by the dea
and so
there's a very wide range of chemical
structures that are out there and that
can make them hard to detect by just a
single test
but if you have the ability to pivot
quickly and to
modify your method then more power tube
i would definitely recommend that but
for most labs by the time we complete a
method development and validation to
meet our regulatory components
there's already new versions of that
drug on the market
another tip would be to keep the panel
as concise as possible
so avoid testing for non-relevant
analytes and so what do i mean by that i
mean
analyze that don't add any value to your
panel because these can cause delays and
turnaround time
and extra costs right so you only get
reimbursed one amount for
your panel no matter how many compounds
are in it and so you have to think
is this really adding anything to the
clinical care for this patient are they
gaining any additional information
consider the return
and finally i'd like to emphasize that
there is no one right answer so i'm
giving
you just some things to think about but
i can't tell you exactly what to put in
your panel
but these are just some ideas to keep in
mind
i'd like to encourage you all to look at
some of the national drug use and abuse
surveillance resources that are
available to the public i find these to
be particularly helpful
so in the next few slides i'll just give
you examples of ones that i've come
across that help me in my practice
so this first one is the annual
surveillance report of drug-related
risks and outcomes which is published by
the cdc
now you could find this information on
their website um and i've just
highlighted two charts that i think are
are quite helpful but just to illustrate
the type of information that you'll find
in these reports
so the first one for example shows the
drug overdose death rate
broken down by the drug or the drug
class per year
right and so here we see that the
prescription opioid death rates have
increased year over year and we also see
now
that the dark horse coming up is the
synthetic opioids
other than methadone which are now the
ones that are mo responsible for the
highest death rates
um another uh important chart that i saw
that i
found to be helpful is that it breaks
down the rates of overdose by drug as
well as
the age of of the patient or
age of the individual
another great resource is the national
drug early warning system so end
dues and so this is funded by the
national institute of drug
of drug abuse so nida so this uh
system there are 12 sentinel hospital
sites that are scattered across the
nation
and they submit indicator data on a
regular basis so enduse incorporates
real-time surveillance to allow us to
detect early signs of potential drug
epidemics and it provides
a nice way to disseminate the data
quickly and in a timely manner so that
we can all act on it
so their reports are published annually
and then they also have a very nice
summary if you don't have the
the um the time to read the full report
as to what trends that they noticed and
so
i've highlighted the four trends for
2020 and i can
i found it interesting that fentanyl
still remains to be the most lethal drug
in many of these undue sites
despite that they're geographically
scattered
another great resource is the samhsa
website so the substance abuse and
mental health services administration
so they have a variety of reports and
tools that are available on that website
one of them is the national survey on
drug use and health and so
an example of some of the data that they
have there is
this shows heroin use in the past year
among adults and so you can see kind of
like in a heat map
which areas herein uses most prevalent
they also uh have reports from dawn so
this is a drug abuse and warning network
and so this shows trends and ed visits
involving illicit drugs and so
it doesn't mean that taking this illicit
drug was the reason why the person was
admitted to the ed or presented to the
ed
it just means that when they were at the
ed and got a drug test
they screened positive for these tests
and so it's interesting to see
what drugs are being mostly abused the
most commonly abused
so you can also gather information on
the local level
from these federal websites or these
national websites so
the nida website um they also allow you
to drill down
and get summaries by your state for some
things and so this is an example of
opioid summaries that are provided by at
the state level
you get information like this so the
first image on the top left
of the united states you can see at the
heat map the opioid involved overdose
death rates across the country and as
you can see
ohio which is where i'm located we are
in the heart of this
opioid epidemic we can then so this we
knew but then it's helpful to be able to
break this down
and look and see okay well these are the
number of drug overdose deaths involving
opioids in ohio
broken down by prescription opioids
synthetic opioids
heroin that's purchased so that's very
helpful to see
we can also look at things like what are
the prescription rates so in ohio we see
that
ohio providers ordered just slightly
more prescriptions or or
wrote slightly more prescriptions than
the average across the u.s
yet it's disproportionate to the number
of overdose deaths that we're seeing
we also can gather information about
admission rates for
substance abuse disorders into treatment
facilities so we can see what drugs are
most commonly being abused and people
are being
admitted to these treatment facilities
for
you may want to also look to see what
type of local
drug use and abuse surveillance
resources are available so we have
something in ohio called the ohio
substance abuse monitoring network
now this is a network that publishes
these pamphlets or these reports about
twice a year
and i find it to be particularly helpful
because it not only breaks it down
for just the state of ohio but by region
so i'm in the cleveland region
and based on this report what i could
see is that fentanyl and marijuana
and methamphetamine availability has
increased while ecstasy availability has
decreased
and from what they're seeing the
consensus is that fentanyl is easier to
obtain than heroin on the streets here
and so that's helpful information for us
and that's what guided us to realize we
have to add fentanyl
to our screen so the national data
coupled with the
local data helped us to understand that
this is really something that we have to
incorporate into our drug panel
and so in the next month or so we will
have incorporated it into our panel
in 22 sites across northeast ohio
i think it's great that they also
provide
more detailed information like what the
current availability is of prescription
drugs as well as
street drugs what the changes in the
availability so whether it's decreased
or increased since the last six month
period
and of those drug categories which
particular drug is the most
commonly available so for example for
prescription drugs
apparently percocet is the most commonly
available
in our area
i also found it particularly interesting
and helpful that the
they also report the most commonly used
cutting agents
that were determined by the crime lab so
we see that for heroin that it's most
often cut with fentanyl
and tramadol in our area and we see that
very regularly so this is also a reason
why we're adding them to our drug
screens
all right so what tips what additional
tips can i give you for keeping your
drug testing panels relevant
well i would regularly check these
national and local surveillance data
tools that i just mentioned
um you may also want to consider
crunching your own positivity rates over
several years
and consider removing drug screens that
don't add any value
you may want to review reference lab
positivity rate data as well so i will
tell you that we were
playing around with the idea of removing
pcp from our panel because
we hadn't seen a positive pcp screen in
a really long time there were very very
few over a three year period
but after consulting with our clinical
toxicologist and seeing information like
this which i'm showing here in the table
uh or the image to the right
that there are actually small pockets in
ohio where pcp is still being abused
it would not be smart for us to remove
it from our panel and so you can
review reference lab positivity data to
see what they're seeing in your area and
see if that aligns with what you're
seeing and this might be particularly
helpful if you're a smaller lab that
doesn't have a very high drug
testing volume so the image on the right
is from quest diagnostics
and it's showing the pcp positivity
rates based on
zip code and it's very hard to see here
but it does show the pockets of
cities in ohio where pcp is still being
used which correlates to what our
clinical toxicologist was also
mentioning
i'd also continue seeking input from
treatment professionals so your
colleagues
you can consider reaching out to the
medical examiner's office
law enforcement in your area and i also
find instrument and assay vendors to be
very helpful for consulting for things
like this they typically have their
fingers on the pulse of what's going on
what's new what's coming out there so
that
they can proactively create commercially
available tests to help us to fight
these pandemics
or epidemics i will always recommend to
attend professional conferences and
seminars to stay up to date on the new
drugs that are coming out
or the new technologies that are
available to help you detect them
and if you are willing to travel down
the rabbit hole with me this last one
is quite interesting it's checking web
forums like bluelight.org
opiophile or reddit threads just to name
a few for open discussions about drug
use
and so it's not a bunch of people
talking about how great drugs are and
trying to promote drug use it's really
intended
um to reduce the harm so that people
will if they are going to use drugs that
they do it more safely
and can have their questions answered
so why would i ever recommend that you
you read these
well there's data and evidence that
shows that social listening data can be
really helpful for monitoring drug use
and misuse and so i suspect that there
will be additional reports that we'll
see
coming out based on what people are
finding by by using social listening to
these threads
so in summary the critical
a critical first step to ensuring that
your drug testing program meets your
stated goals and is successful
is to understand how the testing process
works and what it can and cannot tell
you
i hope that i've demonstrated to you
that drug testing is not a
one-size-fits-all process that there are
varying needs for different patient
populations
and that you really need to consider the
test characteristics that are needed
and i don't just mean analytical i also
mean the clinical and the operational
i encourage you to collaborate with
other departments to develop your
institutional testing guidelines
and to create educational materials to
help them know which test to order in
which scenarios
i'd also encourage you to collaborate
with them to learn about their
experiences on the front line since they
are the first to
see new prescription drugs coming to the
market know how frequently they're
prescribing them
or maybe they're seeing more illicit
drug use that they can tell you that
that something is about to be big in our
area
i also recommend regularly reviewing
these national and local drug use abuse
and overdose trends
and evaluate them against your current
panel to see what you can improve what
you might need to consider adding
removing
and i just want to emphasize that
optimizing your drug testing panel
is an iterative process you can't just
set it up and walk away and never go
back to it
you must regularly go back and check to
see what the climate is around you what
the environment is
what's coming your way and then react
accordingly
so with that i'd like to thank you all
for your time
i'd like to thank thermal fisher
scientific for sponsoring this webinar
and i am happy to take questions
thank you jamie for your informative
presentation
we will now go ahead and start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started your
first
question is
which chromatography technique is best
for drug testing
that's a harder question to answer which
one is best i think it depends on what
drug you're trying to test for so some
drugs are inherently more
volatile than others others you just
will have a really hard time trying to
derivatize them in order to get them to
be label enough for gc to be the good
method so i think it depends on what
panel
you're talking about i think gcms has
historically been the gold standard for
confirmation testing but i think more
and more people are moving to lcms
because it tends to be more robust
so in the sense that you can test for
more drugs without having to derivatize
them
and you can work with a range of
polarities
i hope that adequately answered the
question
thank you okay next question can
immunoassays discern
between delta 9 thc and delta 8
thc i wouldn't
i i don't believe so i mean but i to be
honest i
i don't i don't know the answer to that
one i know that in general
amino acids the antibodies are designed
to
recognize the 3d and chemical structures
and those sound like they are very close
to each other
they will probably be able to detect
both if it's able to detect it
but maybe at different concentrations
but those are very structurally similar
okay all right your next question
can you detect lsd in a urine sample
i'm sure you could detect lsata urine
tip i don't know that anyone is really
using lsd much anymore
but yes
now is the immunoassay used for
drug screen a laboratory test or a poct
well it could be either so it depends on
how you choose to use it
in our system i can tell you that we
have some physician offices that have a
point of care
here in drug screen where they're either
in a cassette based form or a cup
cup form and then we also have one
that's done in the laboratory so on our
larger chemistry analyzer so
the screen can be either but the
confirmation is always the same in our
system so we build it so that they will
all screens that are well i should say
we built all of them but screens that
are positive
always get reflex to our uh lcms
confirmation in our laboratory so there
are several different screening
modalities that are used
okay i've seen this question a few times
um the attendees want to know if the
recording is going to be available
for them to view later and i do want to
let you know that this event will be on
demand
you will be able to to view the webinar
again after it's finished today
okay let's go ahead and move on to our
next question what is the best test for
alcohol
best test um in my time i feel like
it's evolved i think now people are
using ethyl glucuronide more
though i don't know how many labs
actually have it on site
so i will say that in our laboratory we
just test for ethanol
um but we do have several like addiction
recovery services
um and several other specialties that we
send out for ethyl glucuronide
i believe that that is a better marker
we would like to eventually bring that
in house but we have not done so yet and
i know that there are also
several other markers that i see
coming up that would be helpful but i
don't think that they have been adopted
as widely
in in the general clinical lab setting
great thank you now what cut what
cut for amp and benzo is recommended
i'm sorry i don't think i understand the
question yeah this user says
what cut of 4 amps and benzo is
recommended oh what cutoff
what cutoff for amp and benzo is
recommended oh okay
got it um so i think that depends on
what you're using it for
i would say in general for the workplace
drug testing the cutoffs are much higher
but um in the clinical setting it's
quite a bit lower so
i could tell you that we use for our
amphetamine uh screen we use a 500
nanogram per ml cut off
and um a 200 nanogram per ml cut off for
benzodiazepines
so i think that for clinical testing i
would use the
the um the lower cut off so that you're
able to detect more
um if you're doing it for workplace
testing the higher cutoff is better
because you don't want to
pick up on people who are taking things
that they're prescribed you're looking
for
them taking drugs that they're abusing
okay great thank you i think we have
time for a few more questions here next
question
is can screen and confirmation both be
done
on lcms that's a great question
so yes they can actually both be done on
lcms i think that few institutions have
the ability to do that
because lcms is not so common that it's
in every lab these days
but yes they can both be done there are
several institutions that are doing that
now
and just bypassing the immunoassay
screen altogether
so i think that that's probably where
the field is moving towards but i think
that until
more labs can get their hands on lcms
can can have the expertise on site i
think that immunosa will be around for a
while
a very good question great thing thank
you
now if a patient is using cough syrups
or sleeping pills will we get the
positive result
in drug testing
you can you can you get a false positive
or sometimes a real a true positive if
it's an amphetamine
containing medication on a urine drug
screen but that's where the confirmation
testing comes into play to help you
discern whether or not it's a false
positive or true positive
now what about integrity checks
great question so there are a number of
things that you can do to check the
integrity of a specimen i will tell you
that
in-house we have chosen to do a
creatinine check
and this is not for all tests this we've
only included this in our opiate
benzodiazepine prescription compliance
panel
but we'll do a creatinine check to make
sure that it's at a certain threshold
to ensure appropriate concentration of
the urine
um if it is less than that threshold we
will automatically reflex a specific
gravity testing
now i know that there's some labs that
will also look for
adulterants and things like that but we
are not currently doing that in-house
we used to send that out to a reference
lab so that we could have it available
to our clinician should they feel that
it's necessary to do that but we don't
do it in-house
so just creatinine and specific gravity
is what we do in our clinical lab
thank you now this question says
we have a client that takes byvance and
is
positive for amp and manp every urine
test
how do i determine whether he is
actually abusing meth
his drug of choice
so there are higher level methods that
can be used to detect
street amphetamine from what would be
prescribed um we don't run any of those
in-house so you're saying that his
drug of choice is methamphetamine
correct sorry i want to make sure i
heard that correctly yes
correct okay well we can tell the
difference between methamphetamine and
amphetamine in these
these tests um we can also tell the
difference between the dnl
isomers of methamphetamine to determine
whether or not it's coming from an
illicit source versus a prescribed
source
i'm assuming then that this patient has
also been positive for methamphetamine
at some point
and you can differentiate
methamphetamine from amphetamine in your
confirmation test
okay thank you now heroin has a very
small window of testing
what can i do to extend it
i don't know how you can extend the
window i do understand where the
question is coming from that
the very specific metabolite to
heroin acetyl morphine um that's very
labile very volatile doesn't exist very
long but you can detect the morphine
and hydromorphone for quite a bit of
time after use
we're also seeing that a lot of heroin
is cut with tramadol and fentanyl
at least in our population so we're able
to see a very clear pattern of
morphine hydromorphone fentanyl and its
metabolites
so while you you won't be able to detect
that 6am
for very long you can detect the
other metabolites of heroin
further down the pathway
thanks so much jamie we have time for
one more question here
from a technical staffing issue are you
running
lcms testing 24 7
and if so at how many locations in your
system
ah very good question i would love to be
able to write it 24 7 but unfortunately
we don't have the staffing or expertise
to do that
it's been challenging to even bring the
lcms testing in-house because
it's not something that's taught in in
med tech school so we had to
kind of train the staff ourselves to do
this so right now we offer it
only on first shift the intention is to
expand as we bring on other types of
testing to
run it across at least two shifts right
now we're running it only five days a
week
and because of the equipment and the
expertise that's needed
we have concentrated all of our testing
to one site on campus so we are kind of
the mothership hospital we have the
largest hospital in our system
and we receive all of the work from the
12 community hospitals around us
and all of the physician offices that
use our testing services
i can tell you that one of the things
that we have done in order to kind of
streamline this process
is we ensure that people use the same
sample cup
we have special cups that we have them
used so we can sample from directly
onto our sample prep instrument so we've
done things to kind of streamline the
process and still have a great
turnaround time
despite that we're doing the testing for
our whole system in just one location
well thank you again jamie for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank labyrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast and as a reminder before we go
i would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye